welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for Loki season two this show is
returning October 6th and it looks like
in season two we're gonna see the origin
of the TVA in the Victorian era and Ms
minutes in a ghost form scaring more
1893 Chicago wins than H.H Holmes let's
break down this trailer frame by frame
for all the details you missed to see
what's in store for the season and a
reminder that I broke down all of Loki
season 1 over on the Deep dive Channel
and I found a ton of new details so
please give it a watch and subscribe to
that channel and when Loki season 2
returns in October our inside Marvel
after shows will be on the break room
channel so please subscribe to that too
let's get started
who'll be
hello
we have a little bit of a situation we
wanted to run by you Mobius wow great to
see you again
[Applause]
okay the trailer opens with Loki and
Mobius back in the TVA visiting OB
played by kihue Kwan last year's Oscar
winning for everything everywhere all at
once and of course child actor from
Indiana Jones of the tip of Doom and The
Goonies three movies I have broken down
on the Deep dive Channel OB likely
stands for Aura Boris his character's
rumored name named after the ancient
symbol of a serpent eating his own tail
representing cyclic renewal for in this
case time being a loop as the secret
timeline was originally depicted as a
ring looping back on itself Obi works in
the repairs and advancements Department
of the TBA which is fed by dozens of
pneumatic tubes that you see in old tiny
offices the ways to rapidly transfer
letters and documents to different
departments on the walls behind them are
posters for pneumatic tube etiquette and
temperamental temp pad don't delay
repair it today OB descends from the
roof where we can see a clock on the
high wall with multiple hands much like
the clock we saw in the processing room
of Loki episode 1 last season also in
all the episodes credits also in the
background of the office is a gumball
machine obi's uniform has three Cog
patches on the lapel perhaps a symbol or
designation for his role as repairs at
the TVA and there are three cogs which
might have some connection with the
original Three timekeepers who everyone
thought ran the TVA but were actually a
facade for the real ruler of the TBA he
remains a Kang variant remember the Loki
in the series is technically Loki
variant l1130 the variant from the
branch timeline created by the events of
Avengers end game when Tony Stark
fumbled the Tesseract during the time
heist in 2012 and Loki used it to
teleport to Mongolia where he was
promptly arrested by the TBA for
creating a branch timeline Loki was
processed by the TVA and convicted by
rensslayer but Mobius recruited Loki to
help them catch another one of his
variants Sylvie season one ended with
Loki and Sylvie joining forces and
escaping their banishment in the void by
defeating the Beast eliaith and making
it to the Citadel Beyond where they met
he remains a variant of Kang the
Conqueror he remains shared his
backstory as a 31st century scientist
who discovered multiversal travel and
ended up in a multiversal war with his
variants but he remains was the one
variant who's able to use eliaith to end
the war and prune the Multiverse down to
one single sacred timeline he remains
offered Sylvian Loki two options to kill
him and unleash his variants or take his
job and maintain the sacred timeline
Sylvie chose to kill he remains in the
sacred timeline ruptured into countless
branches Loki back in the TVA runs into
Mobius and Hunter B15 who now have had
their memories wiped and the statues at
the timekeepers have been swapped with
one big statue of Kang grenflayer had
left the TBA in search of freedom but we
learned she was once a high school
administrator with the name of Rebecca
tormane quantumania gave us more context
to the Kang's story showing us another
Kang Kang the Conqueror who had been
exiled in the quantum realm after
destroying countless timelines the mid
credit sequence of that movie showed us
the full Kang Dynasty led by immortus
Pharaoh Rama Tut and Scarlet Centurion
overseeing the same sacred timeline that
we saw in Loki so Loki in this trailer
is now wearing the same clothes sword
harness and his sleeve has a cut on it
that we saw him with at the end of
season 1 after his duel with Sylvie in
the Citadel Loki's body stretches and it
looks a lot like bubble gum which makes
the whether it's that gumball machine in
its room pretty important and we learned
this is called time slipping one word
according to the captions it's kind of
like an MCU version of the glitching
that the Spider-Man variants were going
through in the spider-verse movies but
it also visually reminds me of the
unraveling of one of the Scott Langs and
the probability storm in quantumania or
what won a maximoff did to read Richards
in Multiverse of Madness this is kind of
what it looks like when you're being
unstuck from time in reality a bit more
on this in the next section
that's what's been happening wow time
slipping were you times you know that
yeah you've seen that yeah can you fix
that no
it's impossible to time slipping the TVA
I know but we just saw it happen
yeah yes Obi is fascinated to see this
time slipping because it's something
that should not be possible in the TVA
remember the TVA is supposed to be a
neutral zone that is immune for magic
and manipulations to the time stream
time is supposed to flow differently in
the TVA but that seems now to have been
changed since he remains was killed and
now Loki is kind of like Desmond in
season four of lost a figure unstuck in
time see in the past in the future all
at once even inside of the TVA on to the
next section
pulled through time
between the past and the present hello
if what I saw is true
okay we see Loki time slipping in the
time theater number five and then to
this parking lot where an inflatable
yellow figure seems to be mocking his
time slipping so Loki is in front of
piranha Power Sports which sells jet
skis we'll no doubt revisit mobius's
desires for a free life outside the TVA
as represented by jet skis something he
was always fascinated by and actually
this may be mobius's past before he
worked the TVA it's kind of hard to tell
but it may be him behind Loki either
buying or selling a jet ski he's with a
woman and a man who might be a couple or
the other man could be the salesman and
that could be mobius's wife so then Loki
Time Slips back into the main Chrono
monitor observation deck where you'll
see he's wearing that brown variant
jacket that he wore in episode two of
last season a poster on the right says a
tiny cubicle for a healthy timeline and
a post on the left says catch a Nexus
prevent a red line we saw both of these
posters in season one and I think it's
worth noting that the Marvel Studios
title of this trailer has a red
background showing us that we are now in
the red line on the Chrono monitor
screen you can see the sacred timeline
on the left all the time stream strands
are unfurled but that's some kind of
patch in the middle cramming them all
back into one timeline once more on the
right it kind of looks like a sausage
maker grinding loose meat into one tube
so perhaps the TVA is temporarily
patched this branchy Multiverse we see
Sylvie standing in a vinyl record store
as figures and Records all similarly
time slip per time slippage could be
linked to Loki's time slippage you'll
notice that one poster reads camouflage
live in concert camouflage is a German
synth pop band that formed in 1983 and
is part of the new wave movement another
read star tour Donna Doris and then on
the left space concert tickets available
now space was a band from Liverpool
formed in 1993 that embraced Electronica
it's known for an Eclectic mix of sounds
so this record story must exist sometime
after 1993. let's move on there's
nothing
World and Other destruction only one way
to find out
[Applause]
a little good old-fashioned leg work
listen we have different styles you're a
man of action which is fine
okay Loki uses a pruning stick on a
mural of the timekeepers prodding it
directly in the middle of The Hourglass
logo to prune the wall back to reveal
the face of Kang's underneath and the
foreground is the severed head of one of
the timekeeper robots the one that
Sylvie beheaded to reveal that the
timekeepers were just Androids being
controlled by Kang puppets it seems like
this Loki's trying to convince the
memory wiped Mobius and B15 that the
timekeepers are not in control of the
TBA but Kang is they entered an elevator
where the sign of the back reads read
entire sign carefully followed by a long
list of instructions that would take way
too long to read in a typical elevator
ride but in green two lines down is
something about temporal radiation which
is likely referring to the orange tinted
energy that makes up all the technology
the TBA the time doors Miss minutes
herself it's interesting for it to be
described as radiation though because it
means that the TBA and Kang can wield
time as a kind of energy resource it
could be linked to the quantum ore that
Sylvie was shoveling with that aim
shovel at the end of episode 1 Quantum
or could be the raw mineral that is
refined into temporal energy Loki and
Mobius step into a World's fair now
you'll notice they're wearing the same
period costumes that they wore in the
Quan Animania post credit scene a scene
from this upcoming Loki season when they
find Kang variant Victor timely in that
scene Victor timely unveiled the machine
he called his temporal Marvels and said
time is
every
thing it shapes our lives but perhaps we
can shape
it in the comics Victor timely is a king
variant from 1901 timely Wisconsin he
founded the town it was a town that he
uses really as a shield to hide his
hidden Kingdom of chronopolis and Victor
timely in this era is joined by Rebecca
tormente and Alias of rabona rensslayer
and the name she may have at this point
in time in this season the gate they
walk through reads Midway place which is
the original name of Midway Park in
Chicago which is built for the world's
Colombian Exposition in 1893 aka the
Chicago World's Fair behind it we see
the original Ferris wheel which was the
centerpiece of the 1893 Expo this
real-life Exposition was the inspiration
for the Stark Expo that we saw in 1943
in the first Captain America film which
included an exhibit from Phineas Horton
a figure who has a shared history with
Victor timely in the comics the Chicago
World's Fair also has a pretty dark
history it's a backdrop for the mass
murderer H.H Holmes AKA The Devil in the
White City who preyed upon people who
moved to Chicago for the fair and
trapped them in a Murder Castle that he
built he confessed to killing it at
least 27 people use a real piece of
garbage and I bring it up now because it
kind of seems like Loki is suggesting
that 1893 fair was the backdrop to
another villain Victor timely we see
Loki firing his green sorcery when
they're at the fair cutting to an alley
outside a 1970s movie premiere where
Brad wolf gets hit by a blast I think
from a different scene and then back to
the 1893 Fair where Loki gets blown out
of the back of the ferris wheel building
perhaps Loki's duel with Victor timely
won't go down so well do you need energy
do you need it now that's a job for one
shot
one shot Energy Chews are a healthy and
convenient energy boosting supplement
candy for gamers athletes YouTube hosts
everybody really one shot makes energy
choose and focus shoes so that you can
choose if you want to rev up or Zone in
each energy chew has 75 milligrams of
pure caffeine plus 600 milligrams of
additional neurotropics that give you a
serious energy boost that works
immediately as you chew the Focus Shoes
come in new rockstars themed packaging
we use them all the time to get a
natural boost of focus and energy with
BCD and E vitamins plus zinc to help
with immune system support and the amino
acid tyrosine both energy to choose and
focus shoes are plant-based naturally
sweetened and designed to give you the
energy and focus you need without a
bunch of fillers and chemicals get
started with one shot energy today by
going to oneshotenergy.com new rockstars
for 10 off your order okay on to the
next section I take a more slow
deliberate cerebral approach
it's really good buy
[Music]
to us
Mobius and Loki eat some key lime pie at
the TVA cafeteria anything that green
that mass-produced in bulk cannot taste
that good we find ourselves at a London
movie premiere for a film called zaniac
so in the 80s Thor Comic zaniac was a
swarm of demonic parasitic creatures
that originated from the dark dimension
this entity would possess a host and
cause him to develop an overwhelming
bloodlust and desire to kill women
zaniac was also a serial killer
character played by actor Brad wolf in
the comics and then Brad wolf actually
does become possessed by the real zaniac
so Brad wolf is the star of this film
he's played in the show by your actor
Rafael Casal on the Marquee you can see
the names George Ethan Walker Steve
Allen and Leah something we also see
Brad waving the fans of the premiere
later one signed reading Marry Me Brad
wolf also in that shot is a movie poster
on the left in the background with him
as zaniac it looks like Loki confronts
Brad wolf in an alley using Shadows with
glowing horns to pin him against the
wall seems to be a new type of sorcery
that Loki using here because he was
taught witchcraft from his witch mother
Friga and just a visual this reminds me
of the Shadow Demons that drag people
away in the movie Ghost then a quick
shot of Sylvie working at a McDonald's
her uniform she's wearing here is period
specific to the 1970s an actual
McDonald's retro uniform McDonald's is
clearly signed off on this because they
responded to the Tweet of the trailer
with hi Sylvie I like how her name badge
has the old school label maker label
strip on it with a blue background and
The Faded white letters and as an
employee she has five stars Sylvie
attacks a TVA employee in this boat room
that we see more of later but the device
that they're tinkering with seems to
have three temp pads installed so maybe
each of these devices sends each of
these lifeboats to three different safe
timelines from this Arc just a quick
Theory let's move on to save place is
this cracked is it
whatever we do
we're playing God
we are gods
okay we revisit the ruins of he remains
Citadel after Sylvie killed him his body
still sits in the chair that Sylvie left
him in his windows and roof are caved in
and behind them the sky is streaked with
purple and blue lines as the sacred
timeline is going ape OB suits up
Mobius in an all-timey space suit or a
diving suit that has a huge tube
connected to the back and he tapes up
the crack of the helmet with duct tape
like Matt Damon does to his helmet in
the Martian Obi is sending Mobius out on
a walkway through the chaotic temporal
energy ahead of him you can see that
patch that I talked about earlier where
on the left the sacred timeline branches
get bound together going from chaos
formed into one tight rope the idea that
the TVA had this patch ready to go tells
us that the Multiverse exploding is a
contingency that they've gone through
before it reframes Sylvie's spontaneous
choice to stab Kang as something closer
to the anomaly in The Matrix Reloaded
choosing to defy the architect but since
there were six cycles of this anomaly
the architect knew that that was a
possibility I think he remains planned
for all this to happen and I believe
that the Kang Dynasty wanted it to
happen so that they could be free Loki
flips the switch on the device to
torment Brad Wolf the way Moby has
tormented him last season later we see
he traps Brad in a box of temporal
energy Loki's task may be to rid Brad
wolf of the zaniac entity Sylvie tells
Loki we're playing God to which Loki
responds we are Gods notice how this is
the same key lime pie room in the
cafeteria so it seems like Sylvie will
be re-recruited from a different
timeline Loki reminds her that as Norse
mythological deities they are elevated
over normal Mortals but also the TBA
occupies the kind of god-like status
Sylvie unsheaths their sword in a
workshop with mannequins and robotic
body parts I'm pretty sure she's
approaching Victor timely on the floor
in the background there this could be
his lab for temporal Marvels at the
World's Fair my theory is that Victor
timely is the king who invented the TVA
with its Old School Technology and its
archaic bureaucracy these mannequins
with their robotic parts may be Victor's
first models for the timekeepers it
seems like assisting Victor in this
Workshop setting is ranslayer but
perhaps for Rebecca torment a forum she
fires a weapon that seems to be powered
by orange temporal radio maybe a gen 1
pruning Rod onto the next clip
[Music]
make the hard choice
now there is a close-up of Loki holding
this clock device green on one side
right on the other on a scale from 1 to
3.999999 now there is text at the top of
it automatic and then the TVA logo and
then I think the word is timer I don't
know this could be an analog way of
measuring when Loki is in safe green
versus when he's approaching that red
line status which would be when he's
about to time slip the hand is currently
moving back toward the green we see
Hunter B15 perhaps in her past life is a
doctor in a clinic behind her notice is
a Time door but it looks like it's
glitching a bit maybe the TVA it's
coming from it's not in great shape
Eugene Cordero returns as Casey who may
also take on the designation as hunter
k5e or KZ he leads his way through this
dark industrial tunnel and we see Ren
Slayer AKA Rebecca tormente wearing a
frock over the outfit that we saw in
earlier she's also witnessing the Victor
timely presentation and we see a bit
more of that scene as Victor fires up
his Machinery looking a lot like Nikolai
Tesla but the electricity is purple
colored which could be the first Spark
of what it'll eventually form into the
sacred timeline alright let's move on
on its way
always have been
always will be holy Miss minutes or
an early version of her takes the form
of a pale yellow ghost instead of a
clock and she Stomps a guy to the ground
and grows gigantic Tara Strong's voice
shouting you better run some Miz minutes
can appear in the real world outside of
the TVA and she can have a physical
impact she isn't just a hologram or
projection she's physical temporal
radiation who can push things so just
like timely Wisconsin the comics we may
be seeing the origin of the TVA taking
the architecture of the Chicago World's
Fair and building the TVA around that in
a dimension removed from time inside the
TBA Loki points to a mirror wall telling
Mobius that war is on its way and on the
right you see the timekeepers pruning
the sacred timeline but on the left is a
new mural that we didn't see before
depicting eight kangs wearing their
green and purple comic book get up
fighting among a series of discs this
looks a lot like some Mike del mundo art
from the comics depicting Kang from the
Kang War Avengers Unleashed storyline
this could be the same multiversal war
that he remained spoke of and last
season's finale Casey wears some
headphones it turns to see card number
35 reading toward the window behind him
if you look past that car you can see a
big statue of Kang looming over the TDA
architecture a really cool shot of the
Chrono monitor screen unraveling into
these time slipping strings Ms minutes
saying thank you for your service on it
and I love how in the lower right corner
of the screen it just peels apart
perhaps that timeline patch isn't
holding and that's why Mobius needs to
go out and fix it all the tbas turning
in pasta a quick shot of rinselayer AKA
tournament in the void now you can see
purple lighting on her face maybe she is
facing Elias she might have been the
first person that came she remains
Victor timely ever pruned a quick shot
of TVA Hunter is arriving in this
facility lined with wooden boats there
are cots on the other side of this room
in a later trailer shot making me wonder
if we might be seeing a kind of Arc with
lifeboats as Loki fights the hunters
there's a yellow sign of the background
reading deliu Warner and then
b-a-t-b-y-g-g some other letters this is
a nod to Dan deliu long time Marvel VFX
coordinator who is directing at least
one of the episodes this season and he
might have decided to shoot the spicy
seen as a winner AKA an unbroken
tracking shot just like we saw the
Warner through the town on lamentis one
in Loki episode 3 last season and I love
the shot of Loki crossing the frame past
the letters of l-o-k-n-i through a Time
door barrier that wipes the frame and
leaves us with the series title okay on
to the last segment all over the top
don't you think
other spot on
so Mobius reacts to Loki in his
duplication cast itself attacking Brad
quick shot of Loki falling through the
TVA it looks like he passes a sign
reading timeline preservation so this
could be a department that tries to
maintain timelines in a way so that
they're less likely to form Nexus events
or maybe kind of a historical society to
document every timeline that got pruned
out of existence I think this will lead
to him Landing in card 35 and crashing
into Casey because at the bottom of the
screen there it looks like that same
yellow car but this match Cuts with Loki
Landing in a Lifeboat which might be one
of the lifeboats from that Arc setting
it seems to be landing in the water on
some kind of beachfront and I love
seeing this because most of the other
locations we've seen in this trailer are
clearly on a Sound Stage or some bfx
volume location this though looks
practical and Outdoors and then lastly
we see that the huge Green Wave of
energy came from Loki and Sylvie holding
hands in my deep dive of Loki season one
I pointed out that these two Loki
variants learning to dance together was
the key to it all that they unlocked the
power when they join forces that made
them a stronger multiversal Force than
Kane could ever be he does not get along
with his variance we're going to be
talking about this trailer a lot more in
the weeks ahead and I can't wait for her
to come back in October and I just want
to note that for now it looks like
Marvel is sticking with Jonathan majors
in the role of Kang this season as his
legal issues continue to proceed of
course we all know that Kane can take
many forms in the Marvel Comics but we
will wait to see what the outcome of
John the majors trial is I want to thank
Brandon Barrett Eric Francisco and
Jordan Morris with her help on this
breakdown subscribe to all three
channels in the new rockstars Network
and you can support us by grabbing some
merch at nerdrive.shop follow me on all
social platforms at eavos follow me
rockstars thanks for watching bye
thank you